in 2013 Bangladesh signed its biggest
ever contract worth nearly 13 billion
dollars under the deal Russia state-run
company rossitram would build a
country's first nuclear power plant
Moscow is providing 90 of the funding
for the project but Western sanction
against Russia imposed after its
invasion of Ukraine a threatening to
undermine the scheme some experts say
they'll only have minimal impact the
short-term repercussion will be there
and I don't think uh you know one can
continue for longer period because
countries will find a way to resolve
that
money transferred to Russia from
Bangladesh as payment for equipment for
the project have also stalled last month
the U.S sanctioned ship carrying
equipment for the project was turned
away after Bangladesh field reprisal
from the west but not all the equipment
comes from Russia our Machinery comes
from Western Europe so sanctions should
not have any impact on that our works
are progressing pretty well and I think
all the all the work will be finished on
schedule
nearly 5 000 Russians and other
expatriates are working on the scheme
many restaurants shops and small
commercial establishments have sprouted
up in this remote town in Northeast
Bangladesh they're here to cater for the
influx of thousands of Russians and
other foreigners as well as people from
other parts of Bangladesh working for
the nuclear power project
the local economy and the community
appears to be benefiting Philadelphia
Russians ukrainians fellow Russians and
others shop here and they all hang
together and they get along well they
don't seem to have any problems
the conflict in Ukraine seems to have
very little impact here Yuri bodhana is
Ukrainian and says he has no problem
working with the Russians
I've been living here for two years and
I do like it here yes my family right
now is safe in Ukraine
who live here
don't uh
speak about conflict of this conflict
don't
don't mind about this conflict I think
people who live here uh
doesn't
matter what happening there Alexander is
a Russian working at the nuclear plant
and didn't want it to be identified he
thinks sanctions are having no impact I
don't see any kind of problems connected
with and related with some kind of
Western sexiest case where it goes on
Bangladesh government officials didn't
respond to Al jazeera's request for an
interview
Moscow and Washington's rivalry may be
posing a test for daca's policy of
neutrality but here on the ground the
future of this project seems bright
sanvi Chaudhry Al Jazeera rupur
Bangladesh